two mass shootings rock the nation the
media and democrats blame
trump and our social fabric continues to
disintegrate i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
what an absolutely horrifying morning to
be talking about news and politics
obviously
this weekend was just devastating for
the country for a variety of reasons two
mass shootings taking place
one in el paso texas the other in dayton
ohio as it turns out
there was also a mass shooting in
chicago we will get to
all of those we should take these one at
a time because they obviously have
different motivations
they obviously have different
backgrounds there's been a lot of
attempts to conflate
all of these types of shootings under
one broad rubric that is not going to
suffice we have to get very specific
about what exactly caused each of these
shootings
who is to blame what we do about it and
all of the rest so we begin
today with the shooting that everybody
is obviously talking about the most and
that is the shooting that happened
in el paso over the weekend according to
nbc news a gunman opened fire saturday
in a walmart and around a nearby
shopping mall in el paso texas
leaving 20 people dead and 26 injured
law enforcement officials said
in delivering an updated number of
deceased governor greg abbott called it
one of the most deadly days in the
history of texas
he said 20 innocent people from el paso
have lost their lives
it's an unbelievable number and it's
just absolutely
horrifying and one of the big problems
with the country right now is that when
something truly terrible happens to the
country if you go on social media if you
talk
with with people around the country not
in person but you just do it via social
media or on the internet
very often the first thing that happens
is everybody doubting everybody else's
motives
we need to start from the premise that
when americans die
in acts of evil that we're all on the
same page
because we are we're all on the same
page
this is an act of absolute monstrous
evil and as it turns out
very specific type of evil white
supremacist evil and let me tell you
the white supremacists who are on the
move right now
these absolute loser evil
pieces of human debris who are active on
4chan
and 8chan the people who are
coordinating to create
the impetus for attacks like this to
murder innocent people
this this is a cancer it needs to be
wiped out and i've been seeing a lot of
people
who are on the left doing this routine
where when people on the right say this
sort of stuff they well where were you
i was here the whole time guys i was
here the whole time many of us were
back in 2015 i was calling the
charleston shooter a white supremacist
terror a white supremacist terrorist
there are those of us who are fighting
white supremacists and the adjacent
alt-right
for years on end for years on end
and the attempt to play politics with
this to pretend that people aren't
sincere
in their opposition to white supremacy
because they disagree with you about
policy
is disgusting because the fact is white
supremacists
are evil i know it personally i've been
fighting them personally
for years i've expended hundreds of
thousands of my own dollars on security
because of the attacks that i have
leveled
against white supremacists three months
ago the fbi arrested a white supremacist
for attempting to kill my family and me
so i'm fully aware of the white
supremacists and how evil they are been
writing about it for years on end some
of us been part of this fight for quite
a while
and we should all be part of this fight
obviously white supremacy
is not only evil it's anti-american it's
disgusting
it's a cancer that must be rooted out
and again this is not something
that i am new to saying this is
something that many of us on the right
have been saying for quite a while for
the media to pretend that's not the
truth as we'll see
is just a lie and a vicious lie at that
politically driven vicious lie
we're all on the same page a few things
can be true at once one
we all mourn when something like what
happened in el paso
happens two every person of decent heart
thinks that white supremacy is a grave
evil that must be fought
and faced down and destroyed and
eradicated we're all on the same page
about that
and three just because we disagree about
politics does not mean that one
and two are invalid and finally four if
you suggest that three is not true that
our disagreements about policy
are reflective not of different ideas
about the best possible solutions
but they're reflective of sympathies for
evil
then you are part of the problem you're
part of the problem in the country we're
gonna get some more of this
in just one second but first let's talk
about stamps for just one moment i know
it's
really gravedable let's talk about
stamps because the fact is that when you
go to the post office very often you end
up spending too much time
there are lines you have to park in
front of the post office and get a
ticket like i did last time i was at the
post office
well when i'm too busy to go to the post
office i go to stamps.com because
stamps.com is fast and easy they bring
all the amazing services of the us
postal service
directly to your computer whether you're
a small office sending invoices an
online seller shipping out products
even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day stamps.com can handle it
all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official us postage 24 7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just hand it to your mail carrier
or drop it in a mailbox it is indeed
that simple with stamps.com you have
five cents off every first class stamp
up to 40
off priority mail not to mention it's a
fraction of the cost of those expensive
postage meters
stamps.com it's a no-brainer it saves
you time it saves you money it's no
wonder over 700 000 small businesses
already
use stamps.com right now my listeners
get a special offer
it includes a four week trial plus free
postage plus digital scale
no long term commitment go check them
out right now stamps.com click on that
microphone at the top of the homepage
type in shapiro that stamps.com enter
shapiro
okay so to get back to this white
supremacist terror attack
that happened and again this is not the
first this happened in the tree of life
synagogue in pittsburgh just a few weeks
ago
as a white supremacist terror attack
there was the white supremacist terror
attack in christchurch
there's the white supremacist there's
been white supremacist terror attacks
of recent vintage going back to 2015
during the charleston massacre
inside a church but obviously white
supremacy has a long history in the
united states going all the way back
to before the civil war and the
ownership of black folks
and what we saw yesterday from white
supremacists or on saturday
was obviously a grave act of white
supremacist
evil law enforcement sources said that
police identified the suspect now
we on this show and on my website daily
wire we refuse to identify
suspects by name because we don't want
to glorify them we don't want to glorify
what they do because
studies tend to show that there's a
clustering effect that happens when you
pay a lot of attention to the specific
person
and make them prominent and make them
famous it's one of the things that they
want so we don't mention their names
here on the show multiple senior law
enforcement officials believe
that this shooter posted a screed online
just prior to the attack
they say investigators are examining and
posting they suspect is from him and
then they eventually
basically confirmed it okay so
this person released a manifesto now i'm
not going to read this person's
manifesto for the same reason that i'm
not going to mention his name
because i don't believe just as with the
christchurch manifesto that we should be
reposting these manifestos and giving
them airplay
i will however point out a couple of
things about the manifesto specifically
because they're going to come up
in when what we discuss as this guy's
motives
because as we will see the media were
firmly fixed on
putting this one on president trump on
suggesting that this shooting was
directly the fault of president trump
and his rhetoric and his
unwillingness to separate off supposed
unwillingness to separate off
from white supremacists and all of the
rest the walmart shooter
manifesto suggested a couple of things
one
this person suggested they support the
christ church shooter and his manifesto
that means that the christchurch
manifesto
has now been directly linked to three
separate attacks is this one as well as
the tree of life synagogue
shooting as well as this as well as the
christchurch shooting
obviously and this is it's an
agglomeration
of white supremacist memes about an
invasion of our country this is
some of the language that people are
picking up on is that this this attacker
this evil piece of debris who should be
executed at the first available
opportunity
he uh he suggests that this is a
response to a quote-unquote hispanic
invasion of texas as we'll see
this is then used by the media to
suggest that anybody who's opposed to
illegal immigration is in league with
white supremacy which is just disgusting
and a lie
the the person goes on to talk about how
if
america allows increasing hispanic
population
then america will become a one-party
state the democratic party
and this of course is used as an excuse
to suggest that all republicans agree
with white supremacists about
immigration which of course is again a
lie
and then this this shooter goes on to
discuss how there are many republicans
who are pro-corporation meaning
pro-immigration
but those aren't the real those aren't
the real defenders
of america this person says immigration
can only be detrimental to the future of
america
and then this person goes on to talk
about the environment now that part is
being ignored by the media obviously
because environmentalism tends to be in
affect of the left
whereas immigration restrictionism tends
to be
a right-wing thing these days the
shooter suggests
our lifestyle is destroying the
environment of our country this is
creating a massive burden for future
generations
a person quotes the lorax and then
finally this person suggests at the very
end and
what is inconvenience to the narrative
that president trump is the cause of all
of us
the person suggests at the very end that
this has nothing to do with president
trump
says that his ideology has not changed
for several years since my opinions on
automation immigration and the rest
predate trump
and his campaign for president i put
this here because some people will blame
the president or certain presidential
candidates for the attack
this is not the case i know that the
media will probably call me a white
supremacist anyway and blame trump's
rhetoric the media is infamous
for fake news so that is what we know
about this particular shooter at this
time
okay as soon as the shooting happened
basically within 12 hours
there's another shooting and this one
happened in ohio
the shooting in ohio happened outside a
bar in dayton
and a gunman wearing body armor opened
fire
at this ohio bar killing nine people
the ohio shooter was formally named
some of the victims include his 22 year
old sister six of the nine victims were
black police have said they don't think
it was targeted discrimination
because of the short timeline of the
massacre
this shooter was killed by police in
approximately 30 seconds after he opened
fire with a 223 caliber rifle
on innocent revelers enjoying a saturday
night out at 1am according to the sun
the shooter's high school principal told
the dayton daily news
that the ohio shooter was suspended from
school for writing a hit list on a
bathroom wall sparking a lockdown so
there have been some serious red flags
about this again evil piece of debris
this evil piece of debris
politics were very different from the
first evil piece of debris politics
heavy.com uncovered a bunch of
information
about this person that information
includes the fact that he said he would
happily vote for elizabeth warren
praise satan he said he was upset about
the 2016 presidential election results
retweeted a bunch of folks who are sort
of political pundits and
and and video cutters on the left
he tweeted i want socialism i'll not
wait for idiots to finally come round
to understanding so this person is
obviously of the left
tweeted out things like vote blue for
god's sake tweeted out videos from
prominent people on the left now as i
have said
this has been my position on every one
of these shootings going all the way
back to
bernie sanders is a bernie sanders
backing
democrat who decided to shoot up
congressional members at a congressional
baseball game
or all the way back to a a quasi-member
of black lives matter shooting up dallas
police officers back
in 2015. i've said for a long time
politicians and political pundits are
not responsible for violence unless they
actively call for violence incitement
one of the things we're seeing in the
country right now is an attempt to paint
speech you don't like as incitement
hey folks on the left did not incite
this person to violence
and president trump did not incite this
shooter to do what he did
in el paso we have to have very strict
standards intellectually for what counts
as incitement now that is a different
question
from the appropriateness of language and
from whether language is inflammatory
i agree that language can be
inflammatory and wrong but that does not
mean that it incites violence
and failing to recognize the distinction
between inflammatory and wrong
and incites violence allows us to curb
free speech it allows us to crack down
on speech that we don't like
it allows us to blame our political
opponents whether you're on the right or
the left
you can blame elizabeth warren for what
happened in ohio but that would not be
correct you can blame president trump
for what happened in el paso that would
similarly not be correct
we cannot adjudicate whether language
is inciting by the effect that it has
on folks with what we would call in tort
law eggshell skulls
we cannot judge whether a reasonable
person would be incited by a piece of
language
based on what an unreasonable outlier
does
that is violent or evil now again that
doesn't make the language right it
doesn't make the language good
bernie sanders language wasn't right or
good when he talked about how
republicans wanted to kill grandma
barack obama's language was not right or
good when he talked about
how american police are endemically
racist donald trump's language was not
right or good when he talked about
the alt-right or when he talked about
charlottesville that language was not
right or good that is not the same thing
as inciting violence and if we fail to
make that distinction
we're going to end up in a really dark
place in which we're calling on
government to shut down free speech in
which we suggest that our political
opponents are actually engaged in
violence when in actuality they're
engaged in language that makes the
country worse and is bad no question
but that does not actually incite
violence
we'll get to more of this in a second
because it turns out that there are some
more shootings
over the weekend as well and we'll get
to that in just
one second first there's one app that's
going to keep you safe and secure
while you are away express vpns whenever
i travel i'm worried about people who
are stealing my data in fact i'm pretty
worried about people stealing my data on
a regular basis no matter what because
there are lots of people after it there
are hackers after it
they're folks who are who are in big
tech who are after it they're members of
government who are after it especially
if you happen to be abroad this is why
you should be using a vpn the best vpn
that i know is expressvpn it runs in the
background of your computer or phone
and then you use the internet just the
way you normally would you download the
app you click to
connect and voila you're protected i
won't go online while traveling without
expressvpn
you should not either expressvpn it's
the fastest vpn i've tried it costs less
than seven bucks per month
and comes with a 30 day money back
guarantee expressvpn uses new cutting
edge technology called trusted server to
make sure there are no logs of what you
do online so no matter what you're
trying to browse online expressvpn gives
you instant access all over the world
don't travel anywhere this summer
without downloading expressvpn
protect your online activity today find
out how you can get three months for
free at expressvpn.com that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
ben for three months free with that
one-year package visit expressvpn.com
to learn more so again i want to give
you all the facts of
the shootings themselves and then we'll
get into the reaction
which is has been terrible pretty much
across the board
so the the final shootings that happened
were of course the
shootings that happened nearly every
weekend in the city of chicago that we
are supposed to ignore and which the
media certainly will ignore so you have
twenty dead in el paso
and that of course deserves as much
media attention as it's getting and then
we have nine dead in dayton ohio and
that of course deserves as much media
attention
as it's getting and then we have seven
killed and 46 wounded in weekend
shootings
in chicago and this happens nearly every
weekend in chicago and this of course
will get no attention according to cbs
dozens of people were shot in chicago
over the weekend including two mass
shootings in less than three hours on
sunday
in all seven people were killed 46
others were wounded in shootings since
friday evening
more than a dozen people were wounded
one of them fatally in a pair of mass
shootings in the lawndale neighborhood
early on sunday apparently these were
just
dispute related possibly gang related it
is unclear
exactly what the cause of it was so
because
the media tend to look into
causes in order to generate narratives
they are going to cover the chicago
shootings not at all
they will cover the ohio shootings a
little bit more but not much more
because the ohio shootings again
were perpetrated by somebody who's on
the political left and
probably suffered from some sort of
mental illness and then there's the
white supremacist shooting in el paso
texas and that's going to drive nearly
all the media coverage this week which
does show the disparity in how seriously
the media actually take
gun violence in the country and the fact
is that what happens in chicago is
much more typical of gun violence in the
united states
and that is much more typical than what
happened in dayton ohio or what happened
in el paso but the media are going to
focus in on what happened in el paso
because the fact is that that backs a
particular narrative that narrative is
that america is filled with white
supremacists and that president trump
has forwarded
all of that and so you're going to see a
vast disparity between the amount of
coverage
on the ohio shooter and his politics
and the amount of coverage on texas and
you're going to see virtually no
coverage of what happens in chicago
nearly every weekend so for folks who
say they take gun violence seriously the
answer is
if you're only taking what happened in
el paso seriously but you're ignoring
ohio
and more than that you're ignoring
chicago you're not taking gun violence
seriously it's possible you're taking
white supremacy seriously and that of
course deserves to be taken seriously
on its own terms but let's be honest
about what exactly it is that we are
taking seriously
and what is the narrative that is being
performed now we should take all of
these things seriously
all of them again white supremacy should
be taken as seriously it is a form of
terrorism okay white supremacist
terrorism
is terrorism it should be treated as
terrorism now there are certain
differences from for example isis i see
people saying
that white supremacism should be treated
the same as isis isis is a group white
supremacism is an ideology
okay so it's not state-sponsored for
example white supremacism but
that doesn't mean that we shouldn't be
opening the floodgates on the sort of
resources that we use on terrorism to be
used against white supremacism
we should those boards the 8chan boards
the 4chan boards
i've been saying for years at this point
that i hope the feds are monitoring
those places i hope the feds are on top
of it they should be monitoring those
places this is where the incipient
violence is happening
we of course should be unleashing all of
the resources available to us on a law
enforcement basis to fight this and on a
cultural basis
we should be calling out white
supremacism wherever we see it
we should be shouting from the roots
tops about how evil this stuff is
some of us have been doing this right at
the cost as i say
hundreds of thousands of dollars in our
own security some of us have been doing
this
so that is backdrop president trump
reacts to all of us and then we're gonna
see
where the media where people decided to
go for all this because it seems to me
that everything that i've said so far on
the show
should be basically inarguable we should
all agree with all of this white
supremacism
evil mass shootings need to be stopped
we can disagree about the ways to stop
mass shootings but we should discuss the
various ways to solve mass shootings
we're not going to discuss any of them
instead there will be political
political pandering galore and blame
cast
in all of the wrong places for political
reasons the media have an interest
unfortunately in pushing certain types
of narratives at the expense of other
types of narratives
we're going to see a vast disparity in
the amount of coverage now that it's
obvious what happened in ohio
we're going to see a vast disparity
between the coverage of ohio and what
happened in el paso texas
okay so president trump reacts this
morning to what happened in el paso
and here is what the president had to
say the shooter in el paso
posted a manifesto online consumed
by racist hate in one voice
our nation must condemn racism
bigotry and white supremacy
these sinister ideologies must be
defeated
hate has no place in america hatred
warps the mind ravages the heart
and devours the soul now as we'll see
folks in the media they don't care what
president trump actually said this
morning
they're going to go with the narrative
that president trump is responsible for
what happened
in el paso now again they don't hold to
the same logic
they don't i think that president
trump's language on the alt-right in
2015 and 2016
was bad i think it was egregious in fact
okay but
they do not hold to the same standard
with regards to president trump that
they do with regard to other politicians
so bernie sanders is not responsible for
the congressional baseball shooting
elizabeth warren is not responsible for
what happened in ohio
barack obama is not responsible for what
happened in dallas but
president trump is responsible for what
happened in el paso according to the
esteemed members of our media it doesn't
matter
that even at charlottesville where where
trump came under heavy criticism from
people like me
for not being sufficient in his
condemnation of all of the people who
are marching
in that tiki torch ceremony on friday
night on that friday night
where president trump said there are
good people on both sides and he did not
mean of the confederate flag debate go
back and look at the transcript i know
there's this revisionist history going
around
that is not what he said he said there
were good people on both sides of those
marches
he made up in his own head a group of
people marching with the white
supremacists
that but he also we must note he did say
at the time that he did not mean the
white supremacist he did not mean the
neo-nazis he did condemn them
at the time the folks in the media
are suggesting that trump is responsible
for every act
of every shooting that happens he's
responsible for it as we'll see
members of the media are now claiming
that anybody who supports him is
responsible for what happened
at the tree of life synagogue or what
happened in el paso texas and that is
disgusting it's egregious it's cynical
and it's obvious
we all know what you're doing and we'll
see this has become the immediate nerve
so trump
came out this morning and made a strong
statement against white supremacism is
that going to help him
of course it won't not with the people
who are trying to pin this on president
trump of course president trump went on
and he suggested that this is not
a gun problem this is a mental illness
and hate problem
which again i think is obviously true
considering there's something like 300
400 million guns in the united states
and these shootings are carried out by
lone individuals not by
vast waves of individuals across the
country we must reform our
mental health laws to better identify
mentally disturbed individuals
who may commit acts of violence and make
sure those people
not only get treatment but when
necessary
involuntary confinement mental illness
and hatred pulls the trigger
not the gun okay this of course is true
we'll get to more of what president
trump had to say
in just one second first let's talk
about the blinds that are in your home
good blinds are to a home what a good
tie
is to a suit it really does bring it all
together if you look if you walk in your
house and you look around like god this
place kind of looks dingy
that may be because of the window
coverings that you are using but
shopping for blinds is not actually
something that i'm great at blinds.com
makes it really fast and really easy
however which is why
i love them with 15 million windows
covered over 30 000
five-star customer reviews blinds.com is
america's number one
online retailer for affordable quality
custom window coverings every order gets
free samples free shipping a free online
design consultation
you just send them pictures of your
house and they will send back custom
recommendations from a professional
for what will work with your color
scheme furniture and specific rooms they
will even send you free samples to make
sure
that everything looks as good in person
as it does online they've made it really
easy for you so there's no
excuse to leave up the mangled blinds or
worse have no blinds at all because well
you know that's going to be
inappropriate for those who are outside
for a limited time my listeners get 20
bucks off at blinds.com when you use
promo code ben that is blinds.com promo
code ben for 20 bucks off
for wood blind cellular shades roller
shades and more blinds dot com promo
code ben
rules and restrictions do apply again
that's blinds.com promo code ben okay so
president trump continues along these
lines
he says that our nation is overcome with
shock horror and sorrow which obviously
is true
fellow americans this morning our nation
is
overcome with shock horror and sorrow
this weekend more than 80 people were
killed or wounded
into evil attacks okay and then the
president went on to talk about what he
wanted to do about it he directed the
doj to propose legislation
putting the death penalty on white
supremacism
white supremacists who commit terror
attacks today
i'm also directing the department of
justice to
propose legislation ensuring that those
who
commit hate crimes and mass murders face
the death penalty and that this capital
punishment be delivered quickly
decisively and without years of needless
delay
okay and then trump called on everybody
to set aside partisanship
and move forward with some common
solutions good luck with that
now is the time to set destructive
partisanship aside so destructive
and find the courage to answer hatred
with unity
devotion and love okay so
this was all the predicate this is all
the baseline where again we should all
agree with what
the president is saying you don't have
to like the president to agree with what
he's saying the words coming out of his
mouth today
are the correct words that is obvious
okay but as we'll see as we'll see
what's actually happening is is
something truly ugly in the country and
that
is an attempt to not only blame trump
for what happened
in el paso but to suggest that anyone
who agrees
with anything trump has done policy-wise
is responsible for the mass shooting of
innocence
and this is cynical it is disgusting
it is un-american it is wrong
okay and we'll see this it's a very
common tactic it's not just a tactic
being used by presidential candidates
and it's
it's a tactic that is now being used by
members of the media on a broad scale
and then
i do want to talk about some possible
solutions things that we can do
to stop all of this because we're seeing
the same sort of solutions being
proposed over and over assault weapons
bans
the sort of policies that didn't work
back from 1994 to 2004 when there was an
assault weapons ban
in place if you talk about video games
again not a lot of evidence linking
video games to mass shootings
we'll get to all of that in just a
second okay so
all of this is backdrop to how people
reacted and i promise you
that all of this is going to get worse
if the theory is that inflammat again
here's my theory
incitement is a specific standard you
did not incite violence unless you
called for violence
however inflammatory language can boil
the pot to the point
that there that there's bubbles jumping
out of the pot right that there
there are sparks that are jumping out
from beneath the pot and
as the heat as the rhetoric turns up the
inevitable side effect is going to be
that there are people with eggshell
skulls who go out and do stuff that does
not mean
that the people who are speaking in
inflammatory but non-inciting terms are
responsible for the incitement
it does mean that you can expect that
things are going to get worse in the
country both in terms of violence and in
terms of politics
when we scream at each other and yell at
each other and blame each other
for incidents like this and when we
don't all speak out forcefully against
evil when we see it
it is it is the responsibility the sheer
and absolute responsibility of every
decent human being in the united states
to shout out to cry out about the evils
of white supremacy to target white
supremacy
to to cut it out amongst your friends
now i doubt how there are many people in
my audience who have friends who are
white supremacists
i really doubt that but if you see the
beginnings of it
quash it in the bud fight it at every
step fight it it's not funny
it's not memory it's disgusting it's
been disgusting since 2015 2016.
again when i was the number one target
of white supremacists online in the
united states in 2016 so i'm
i'm very familiar with these with these
pieces of bleep
very familiar okay so in any case one of
the other things that happens
and and this is not going to make
anything better is the attempt to lump
in everyone who disagrees with you with
a class of people who want to commit
violence against others
because what that really does is it
suggests that anybody who you disagree
with is an enemy to be fought because
if we believe that white supremacism is
a cancer and then you label anyone you
disagree with a white supremacist
what you're saying is that everyone you
disagree with is part of the cancer
so this starts off over the weekend with
various democratic politicians
campaigning for president blaming trump
for the shootings
in a way that nobody has ever blamed
barack obama nor should they
for the shooting of police officers in
dallas nobody's ever blamed bernie
sanders for the
for the shooting of congress congress
people elected congress people
at a congressional baseball game in
virginia rightly people have not blamed
bernie sanders for that
people are not blaming elizabeth warren
for the ohio shooting as they should not
people are not blaming members of the
media who are retweeted
by this ohio shooter for all of this as
they should not
but trump again i'll rip his language as
much as the next guy more than the next
guy okay i've spent my career doing it
for the last several years when the
president is
when trump is wrong and when he says
something vile i say that he is wrong
and says something vile that is not the
same thing
as doing what folks on the left are
doing which are i mean beta o'rourke
went out there and said that trump is a
white nationalist or white supremacist
there is no evidence of that
the best evidence of any of this the
worst you can say about trump
is that he has failed to adequately
condemn white supremacy
and the alt-right and i think that for
2015-2016 that was true i don't think
that that is true for 2018 2019
still that that was a that was a grave
evil but that is not the same thing as
saying he is a white supremacist or
white nationalist
here is here but and beto didn't stop
there of course
beto then when he he said that it was
trump
trump is a white nationalist and then he
blamed fox news so let me get this
straight
if you are president trump and you say
that the news is fake news because they
tolerate garbage like this
then you're very bad and you're
attacking the press but if beta o'rourke
says that fox news is responsible for
mass shootings in el paso that is not an
attack on the press that is just him
being a rational reasonable human being
here's beto o'rourke desperate for
attention and saying something truly
awful
this president is encouraging greater
racism
and and not just the racist rhetoric but
but the violence
that so often follows do you think
president trump is a white nationalist
yes i i do and again uh from
some of the record that i just recited
to you the the things that he has said
both as a candidate uh and then as
the president of the united states this
cannot be uh open for for debate he is
saying that some people are
inherently defective or dangerous
reminiscent of something that you might
hear
in the third reich not something that
you expect in the united states of
america
he is an open avowed racist and is
encouraging more racism
in this country okay this is pathetic i
understand that beta o'rourke is writing
in three percent in the polls but this
is pathetic
i mean i i don't know how to attribute
this to an honest mind
so i'm i have two choices here either he
honestly thinks this
in which case he is disturbed or he does
not believe this in which case he is a
cynical politician desperate for
attention
so i don't think he's disturbed i think
this is a cynical ploy i don't think
that he really believes that trump is a
white nationalist
he may believe that trump is insensitive
on race he may believe that deep down
trump is a racist
by calling him a white nationalist
somebody who wants to get all the brown
and black people out of the country
there is
no evidence like none no evidence of
that whatsoever
and we'll see the media go back they
take some of trump's comments out of
conte again
i've ripped trump when i think his
language is wrong but the suggestion
that trump is himself a white
supremacist or white nationalist
who is responsible for a white
supremacist shooting in el paso is
insane
and o'rourke doubled down on this clip
20. he was asked by the press
and he lost it supposedly he lost it
he was in el paso for some sort of event
obviously commemorating the people who'd
been murdered
and here's what he had to say he's been
calling mexican immigrants
rapists and criminals um i i don't know
like
members of the press what the hold
on a second
you know i i it's these um it's these
questions that you know the answers to i
mean
connect the dots about what he's been
doing in this country um
he's not tolerating racism he's
promoting racism
again this is it's tiresome
you can criticize trump's rhetoric and
in many cases you should go back to my
show two weeks ago i ripped him a new
one
for his tweets about the squad and i
despised the squad
i thought that was really bad xenophobic
stuff but
by the way he did not suggest that all
mexican immigrants are rapists and
murderers he did not do that
when people say that he uses the the
infestation language about
illegal immigration he was specifically
referring to ms-13 when they say things
like
well he called immigrants animals he was
specifically referring to ms-13
if you want to find aspects of president
trump saying awful awful things you
don't have to dig this far
and you don't have to mischaracterize
what he had to say but the attempt to
blame him
for every act of evil that happens in
the united states as we'll see is really
not about trump
it's really about something broader if
it were really about trump
then presumably when trump starts
ripping into white supremacy you'd be
saying good i'm glad he's doing that but
that's not what the left is doing
instead what the left is doing is they
are attempting to link what he says
with policies they don't like and then
say anybody who supports those policies
is now responsible for white supremacy
and it was not just beta or work over
the weekend it was not just beta or work
over the weekend
as we'll see it was cory booker and
elizabeth warren and julian castro and
bernie sanders
and all the members of the media we'll
get to that in just one second first you
need to go subscribe over at
dailywire.com
for 9.99 a month and get a subscription
99 a year gets you our famous leftist
years hot or cold tumbler you can go
check that out which is
fun but not serious folks nobody is
interested in making people cry just for
the fun of it you can go check us out
over at dailywire.com we're the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
it wasn't just beto of course cory
booker who is also riding low in the
polls
went on cnn and suggested that president
trump is responsible for all of this
i think that at the end of the day
especially because this was
a white supremacist manifesto uh that i
want to say with more
moral clarity that donald trump is
responsible for this
he's responsible because he is stoking
uh
fears and hatred and bigotry he is
responsible because he's failing to
condemn
white supremacy and see it as it is
which is responsible for such a
significant amount
of the terrorist attacks okay i'll
explain in a second why this is so
radically dishonest it's radically
dishonest for a couple of reasons one it
is radically dishonest because again
nobody blamed obama for the dallas
police shooting because he was not
responsible for the dallas police
shooting nobody blamed bernie sanders
for the shooting in virginia because he
was not responsible for the shootings in
virginia
and trump is not trump is not calling on
people to go shoot
mexican americans at an el paso walmart
nobody is where are you getting that
where again i can
this is a major distinction i can hate a
lot of trump's rhetoric i can think a
lot of trump's rhetoric
sucks and is gross i can think i can
think it's xenophobic i can even think
that some of it
is racist like when you talked about a
mexican judge back in 2016 being
unqualified because he was mexican and
was going to discriminate against him
and all of this
that is not the same thing as he
promoted murder at walmart in el paso
it's not okay and all these same
democrats were defending al sharpton
five minutes ago
al sharpton actively incited riots twice
in new york city and all these people
were defending him so
spare me your crocodile tears now when
you suggest that
inflammatory language is responsible for
violence either it is or it's not
and obviously it only is if it's one
side of the aisle according to democrats
my feeling again
for the one million time on this show
and others incitement is incitement when
it is
incitement when you're calling on
somebody to commit acts of violence al
sharpton actually did that back into the
back during the freddy's fashion mart
routine and back during the crown
heights routine allegedly
okay but the fact is that this is more
political than anything else as we will
see because it
as we'll see it's not an obvious attempt
to make the country better by rooting
out bad rhetoric
as we'll see this is connected to
something deeper okay elizabeth warren
then rips into fox news
now she's not ripping into trump anymore
now she's ripping into fox news
quote we need to call it out fox news is
a hate-for-profit machine
that gives a megaphone to racists and
conspiracists weird cnn had on richard
spencer like a week and a half ago
to rip on trump so isn't that
interesting but elizabeth warren again
is this attack is this an attack on the
press
is the idea that fox news is responsible
for this now now this sort of mentality
is what leads
to exactly the sort of free speech
crackdowns
that so many people in america are
afraid of fox news is now responsible
for a shooting in el paso despite no
evidence linking fox news to the
shooting in el paso
bernie sanders did the same thing and
bernie sanders the last person who
should talk about this given the fact
that a guy spouting his rhetoric shot a
bunch of congress members
just a couple of years ago but here's
bernie sanders suggesting that trump's
racist rhetoric is assigned to take up
arms
look i am sure that president trump does
not want anybody in this country
to go around shooting other people but
what he has got to
understand is that when you have
language that is racist that is
virulently
anti-immigrant there are mentally
unstable people in this country who see
that as a sign
to do terrible terrible things
so i think the president has got to stop
that racist
racism and that xenophobia immediately
i agree that the president's rhetoric is
that trump's rhetoric has been wrong
many many times but bernie sanders
suggesting that inflammatory rhetoric
is the cause of violence kind of kind of
rich coming from
again a person whose rhetoric was
heavily involved in inspiring according
to bernie sanders his own standard a
shooting of
congress members i understand that that
was out of the way out of the news in
like a week
because of course it was a person of the
left
who had committed this this heinous act
but again you got to have some sort of
consistency here now the media response
to this has just been
has been insane almost almost fully
insane
so let's start with raza aslan and so
if the idea here is that we all need to
come out and condemn white supremacy
then when people do it wouldn't you be
happy well raza aslan
is a it was a former cnn commentator did
some
did some documentaries with cnn
kellyanne conway tweeted
tweeted out we need to come together
america finger pointing name calling
screaming with your keyboards is easy
yet
it solves not a single problem saves not
a single life working as one to
understand depraved evil and to
eradicate hate is everybody's duty
unity let's do this reza aslan
immediately responded
you are the depraved evil we need to
eradicate so kellyanne conway is the
depraved evil we need to eradicate
and this as you'll see the bleed over
from trump's rhetoric is bad and harmful
two everybody on the right is
responsible for this everyone i disagree
with
is a terrorist inspirer was very quick
from the media very very fast
reza aslan then tweeted out after today
there is no longer any room for nuance
the president is a white nationalist
terror leader
his supporter he's a really bad white
nationalist terror leader considering
that he came out today and gave a full
speech about how evil white supremacy is
very bad at his job reza aslan says his
supporters
all of them are by definition white
nationalist terror supporters the maga
hat is a kkk
hood and this evil racist scourge must
be eradicated from society
obviously he's either insane or he's
wildly intellectually dishonest
i think that it is the latter because i
don't think that aslan is insane but the
the
notion that every single person in the
united states who voted for trump or
plans on voting for him in 2020
backs racist shootings in an el paso
walmart
is patently disgusting and ridiculous
and this was the line
from a lot of folks in the media
yesterday and again
they're they're applying standards that
they would never apply to folks on their
own side of the aisle so here's the
anderson cooper suggesting you know
white supremacists are copying trump's
words that means that trump is
responsible
the alleged killer who as always we're
not naming traveled more than 600 miles
from his home near dallas texas
to a city that's more than 80 percent
hispanic his name is on a hate-filled
manifesto posted on the website
8chan shortly before the killing began
it is hard to ignore the fact that they
echo
sometimes even using the exact same
language some of the themes of this
president
of a nation under siege being invaded
facing an
infestation these the president's words
and they can't be denied
okay so if the stan if the standard is
that there's an evil person who went in
an evil thing and was quoting
other people and they're responsible for
his evil then maybe we should talk about
that ice attack that happened a couple
of weeks ago where a person attempted to
attack an ice facility while quoting
alexander ocasio-cortez
and calling it a concentration camp oh
we didn't do any media coverage of that
i i wonder why
i wonder why again there is no common
standard it's not what about ism okay
what about ism
is where you say that the rhetoric is
good i've said the rhetoric is bad all
the way through here
okay and i've been condemning trump's
rhetoric on a wide variety of scores for
years
he said it's not about that and i've
been condemning aoc's rhetoric and
sanders's rhetoric and a lot of this
kind of stuff
but i also have a common standard which
is that aoc and bernie sanders and obama
and trump
are not responsible for the actions of
evil outliers who go and do evil things
that the people who said stuff never
would have approved in the first place
obviously
okay but the media don't hold that same
standard they don't
at all abc news did the same thing they
had a panel yesterday
in which everybody sort of suggested
that trump has to answer for the mass
shootings
again same people nothing when it was
obama and when it was a dallas
dallas police officers being gunned down
in the streets then it wasn't obama has
to answer for anything
then it was we have a systemic problem
of violence and distrust between blacks
and whites and
and problems with law enforcement and
all the rest
lack of a consistent standard is a is
one of the things that raises the
temperature
it's not just the media are wrong here
is that if they are talking about
raising the level of tension in the
country
it is true that the media raised the
level of attention with double standards
with attempts to lump in
everybody who they don't like with
people who commit acts of heinous evil
here's abc doing this is it fair
john to tie the president to this
violence well dan whether or not it's
fair he's going to have to
answer those questions the bottom line
is this president has had
a rhetoric on immigration and on
immigrants
uh that has been deeply divisive so so i
love this
whether it's fair or not he's going to
have to answer those questions well
really because who's asking them
would that be you because it seems to me
that you should answer the question as
to whether it's fair before he said well
regardless he's going to have to answer
those questions
bernie sanders didn't have to answer
questions and neither did obama
if you want to ask those questions fine
but they need to be evenly applied
otherwise there's no standard and this
undermines trust in the media it
undermines trust in each other it means
that we believe that
it means that we on the right believe
that you guys are being cynical that you
don't actually wish
to wipe out white supremacism nearly as
much as you wish to lump in people on
the right with white supremacists so
that you can come after everybody on the
right
and i think there's fairly good evidence
that there are members of the left who
are cynically using this for that
purpose which makes me sad we're all on
the same
god bleep page we're on the sit we
should be on the same page
this is not difficult and the washington
post has a headline today how do you
stop
these people trump's anti-immigrant
rhetoric looms over el paso massacre
again i've condemned
nearly every point that trump has ever
said about this
but that does not mean that trump is
responsible for the el paso massacre
this is an important important point
and let's point something out here is
where here's where the rubber meets the
road where is all of this going
here's where all of this going so the
washington post
runs an editorial today from the
editorial boulder talking about
how trump is very very very mean and
very very bad
and they start off like this we know by
now not to waste time calling on
president trump to do the right thing
he sows division and bigotry rather than
promoting unity and understanding
whatever he promises in the crunch he
capitulates to the gun lobby
and there it is right there it is in
order for trump
to buy off the left in order for trump
to uh to be allowed to suggest that he
is anti-white supremacy
he has to access he has to acquiesce to
all
of their particular policy preferences
so they write a sample speech for trump
and here's what the washington post
wishes he would say quote
my fellow americans these are dark days
and nights of august
a weekend a time americans gather at the
beach the mall a music festival
has brought us horror let us resolve to
transform our great anguish
into action permanent and effective
action this horror will no longer be
normal in our country
today i'm calling on washington i'm
calling on congress to return to
washington for an immediate joint
session
to give up their district politicking
and take action to combat gun violence
enact a ban on sales of military-style
assault rifles as well as high-capacity
magazines
this weapon was made for war it doesn't
belong on our streets make background
checks mandatory
so in other words in other if for trump
to buy off the washington post it's not
about him
condemning white supremacy or fighting
white supremacy or sicking the doj on
white supremacy
or monitoring 8chan it's not about any
of those things
it's about him embracing the proper gun
control policies and charles blow does
the same thing at the new york times
today quote
terror and policy two sides of white
nationalism
the white supremacist terrorists and the
white supremacist policymakers
share the same mission charles blow
official
columnist on the editorial board over at
the new york times suggesting that the
white supremacist who shot up
a walmart in el paso is the same at root
as white policy makers in congress who
happen to be republican
you wonder why i don't trust your take
on white supremacy because of your
suggestion perhaps
that if i am in favor of more
restrictions on illegal immigration
on the border that i'm in the same
basket as a guy who just shot up a
walmart
maybe that's why we don't trust you in
the media to set these standards
maybe that's why republicans won't
appear on cnn you guys
charles blow says is this stochastic
terrorism at play
in which rhetoric by some incites action
by others possibly
there's no doubt that trump and
republicans are making poisonous
anti-immigrant rhetoric part of their
platforms but i think laying all the
blame at their feet is too convenient
and simplistic i think a better way to
look at it is to understand that white
nationalist terrorists
young and rash and white nationalist
policymakers older and more methodical
live on parallel planes planes both
aiming in the same direction
both with the same goal to maintain and
ensure white dominance and white
supremacy
that policymakers believe they can
accomplish with legislation in the legal
system
what the terrorists are trying to
underscore with lead in the mind of the
policymakers border walls anti-immigrant
laws voter suppression and packing the
courts
are more prudent and permanent than
bodies in the street but try telling
that to a young white terrorist
who distrusts everyone in washington
the terrorists want to do quickly what
the policymakers insist must be done
slowly so the terrorists stew
in their anger so in other words
i mean the end of this column is so
morally egregious
charles blow is morally bankrupt morally
bankrupt on the highest level what a
what a disgusting column he says it's
not simply a matter of whether trump's
rhetoric
or any other politician led these
shooters to do what they did maybe
it is also about recognizing that all of
these people are on the same team
and share the same mission and eat from
the same philosophical trough
it's just that their methods differ the
white supremacist terrorists and the
white supremacist policymakers are bound
at the hip
so in other words i disagree with
charles blow about immigration therefore
i am responsible for a shooting in el
paso to that i have two words and one of
them is unprintable
i've taken more abuse from the white
nationalists and white supremacists than
charles blow has i promise you that i've
spent more on security
i've gotten more death threats i will
fight those people to my dying breath
they are the e they are evil they are
the scum of the earth
and your suggestion charles blow that if
i agree that legal immigration
should be expanded and illegal
immigration should be curbed on the
southern border
and that we should expand services on
the southern border for people who are
detained that i'm in the same boat
as a piece of direct who goes and shoots
innocent people
f you and f the horse you wrote in on i
mean this is just
you want you want to keep you want to
keep this boiling point high keep doing
this kind of stuff guys
really well done well done we could all
be on the same page
we could all be the brothers and sisters
we're supposed to be where something
tragic and evil happens in the country
and we all come out and we all say how
evil it is and then we figure out ways
to solve it and we figure out ways to
fight it or you could politic off the
back of it you can start fundraising
like kamala harris did over the weekend
he could go out on national tv and
suggest that the president is
responsible for inciting violence when
he's never called for this sort of
violence he could suggest that everyone
who votes for the president
or gives money to the republican
national committee is responsible for
this or that the nra is responsible for
this or he could be a responsible
american
and join the rest of us and actually try
and figure out what the hell to do about
all of this but i don't think that's
what a lot of folks want to do today
i think what a lot of folks want to do
today is help rip down the social fabric
that is necessary to prevent all of this
you want to know why more and more
shootings are happening because we are
more isolated because we don't trust
each other because the social fabric is
fraying and instead of rebuilding those
institutions you're setting the
institutions on fire
and then you're suggesting you've done a
world of good by burning down the entire
the entire city you burn down the palace
and then you're surprised when we stand
weeping in the ashes well done everyone
what a great weekend well done everyone
in a second we're going to talk about
some of the solutions that have been
proposed
and again how this really isn't about
solutions for a lot of folks for a lot
of folks this is about demagoguery and
scoring political points
and then we'll talk about some actual
solutions because believe it or not
there are some actual things
that we could do today i mean the
the response to this stuff is just
egregious
it breaks it breaks my heart that we
can't all be
on the same page on this why aren't we
all on the same page on this
why in the name of god can't we be on
the same page in the easiest thing ever
fighting white supremacist terrorism
it's the easiest god bleep thing in the
entire world
man i really have to try hard not to
curse today it's it's the easiest thing
in the entire world and somehow
we're managing to botch it somehow we're
managing to botch it
how how okay so some of the solutions
that have been proposed okay so
let's talk about what actual solutions
would look like and then we'll see how
the battery is taking place
okay so there is a piece in the la times
talking about mass shootings and what
they've learned about shooters
by julian peterson and james densley it
says in the last week more than 30
people have died in three separate mass
shootings in gilroy el paso
and dayton ohio and people didn't pay
attention to the gilroy shooting because
again
the media liked to pay attention to
narratives that underscored their
political themes
they don't pay attention to mass
shootings that don't underscore those
political themes per se
and so these writers say for two years
we've been studying the life histories
of mass shooters in the u.s
for a project funded by the national
institute of justice the research arm
of the uscoj we've built a database
dating back to 1966
of every mass shooter who shot and
killed four or more people in a public
place
and every shooting incident at schools
workplaces and places of worship
since 1999. our goal has been to find
new data-driven pathways
for preventing such shootings our data
reveal four commonalities among the
perpetrators
of nearly all the mass shootings we
studied first the vast majority of mass
shooters in our study
experienced early childhood trauma and
exposure to violence at a young age
the nature of their exposure included
parental suicide physical or sexual
abuse
neglect domestic violence and or severe
bullying the trauma is often a precursor
to mental health concerns including
depression
anxiety thought disorders or suicidality
okay so thing number one we can do we
can make sure that kids are better taken
care of
maybe one of those things involves
re-involving ourselves
in the fostering of communities and
making sure that stable two-parent
households stick together
and making sure that people are better
parents and creating social
consequences for folks who are not okay
second practically every mass shooters
we
studied had reached an identifiable
crisis point in the weeks or months
leading up to the shooting
they'd often become angry and despondent
because of a specific grievance
for workplace shooters a change in job
status was frequently the trigger
for shooters in other contexts
relationship rejection or loss
often played a role such crises were in
many cases communicated to others
through a marked change in behavior an
expression of suicidal thoughts or plans
or specific threats or
violence okay so one of the things that
we should be pursuing in response to
this particular concern it was what
david french has pointed out for years
now
gun violence restraining orders which
would allow people who are close
to potential shooters to call up the
authorities and then have them prevented
these people who don't have a criminal
background from being
able to buy guns for a prescribed period
of time
and for a judge to continue that for as
long as the person
is unhealthy and these are called gun
violence restraining orders they are
backed by people across the political
spectrum
they should be fairly easy to do
david french wrote about this back in
2017 he said a well-crafted gvro law
should contain the following elements it
should limit those who have standing to
seek the order to close relatives
those living with the respondent and
perhaps also school principals or
employers so you see somebody starting
to break down
you can call the cops and then you can
get the person in front of a judge for
an assessment as to whether they should
be able to own or buy weapons
two it should require petitioners to
come forward with clear and convincing
evidence that the respondent is a
significant danger to himself or others
three it should grant the respondent an
opportunity to contest the claims
four in the event of an emergency ex
parte order a full hearing should be
scheduled quickly
ideally within 72 hours and five the
order should lapse after a defined
period of time
unless petitioners can produce clear and
convincing evidence of the continued
need right that would be
a fairly good tailored solution to the
problem of tipping points
for potential shooters third according
to the li times most of the shooters had
studied the actions of other shooters
and sought validation for their motives
people in crisis have always existed but
in the age of 24-hour ruling news and
social media
there are scripts to follow that promise
notoriety and death societal fear
and fascination with mass shootings
partly drives the motivation to commit
them
hence as we have seen in the last week
mass shootings tend to come in clusters
they are socially contagious
perpetrators study other perpetrators
and model their acts after previous
shootings
many are radicalized online in their
search for validation from others
that their will to murder is justified
okay so there have been a couple of
measures that could be taken to deal
with this one
is a voluntary measure undertaken by the
media not to name the shooters
how difficult is this guys we've been
doing it at daily wire for at least a
couple of years
as soon as we recognize the danger we
stopped printing the names of shooters i
won't mention them on my show
you shouldn't either don't make them
famous don't make them famous don't
print their full manifestos you can
discuss what the generalized views are
but printing their manifestos makes them
famous as we saw from the christchurch
shooting
taking that seriously would be one
measure measure number two
and there's been a lot of controversy
today over what should be done with
8chan 8chan is this is this
board that has now been populated by the
reprobates of the internet by a lot of
white supremacists and
people who are coordinating and cheering
on violence and all of this
now one of the problems with shutting
down access to 8chan is that it actually
is right now a centralized area that law
enforcement can actually follow right i
mean
once you get rid of it it goes
underground again and then it's harder
for law enforcement to follow so while
it may be worthwhile for companies to
want to disassociate and not
work with hn i get it right that's
cloudflare that's what they did today
and i fully sympathize with the
corporate decision making behind
cloudflare
at the same time i'm not sure that's
actually a good law enforcement strategy
and you'd want to talk with people from
the fbi or doj
to determine whether that is productive
or counterproductive that's a
practicality question
not necessarily a moral question fourth
according to the la times the shooters
all had the means to carry out their
plans
once someone decides life is no longer
worth living and that murdering others
would be a proper revenge
only means an opportunity stand in the
way of another mass shooting is an
appropriate shooting site accessible
can the would-be shooter obtain firearms
in 80 of school shootings
perps got their weapons from a family
member according to our data workplace
shooters tended to use handguns they
legally owned
other public shooters were more likely
to acquire them illegally in other words
maybe there's gun measures we can take
and maybe there's not and this is where
we get into the gun control
talk okay so there have been this is
where you get into
the danger of people demagoguing the
issue specifically because
when it comes to gun control you need to
narrowly tailor these laws because
a hundred million people in the united
states minimum maybe 150 million people
in the united states
actually own weapons there are 300 to
400 million weapons in circulation
in the united states any suggestion that
you're going to criminalize gun
ownership
you're going to come confiscate hundreds
of millions of guns across the country
is likely to end in a lot more violence
and bloodshed particularly because we do
have a second amendment that is
well-based
and all of the talk about how gun
violence is endemic to gun ownership is
simply not true
when you look to vermont or new
hampshire which have extraordinarily
high levels of gun ownership but
extraordinarily low levels of gun
violence in any case
you have politicians demagoguing this by
shouting to the sky do something this
has been the typical way
in which we deal with this stuff so you
end up with
for example kamala harris coming out and
saying i'm going to do something about
guns what is the something
what is the something she doesn't make
that clear but it's something guys
that's demagoguery okay when you can't
name the solution
or when your solution is obviously not
tailored to the problem
it's just throwing crap against the wall
to see what sticks
and you're doing it while sending out
fundraising letters and apparently
kamala harris did over the weekend
that's demagoguery what is your message
to president trump and republicans in
congress
have the courage to act do something do
something
because when i'm elected president i'm
going to do something
that's my message okay so your message
is that you're unilaterally going to do
something what is the something that
you're going to do
and there's an editor at the global
opinions at the washington post
karanatya
who tweeted out something similar and
she tweeted out
and get the exact tweet because a lot of
us reject this vision of america that
tolerates regular mass shootings
as if they are unpreventable natural
disasters doing something more
constructive
is dismantling america's gun culture gun
control now that is the head
of global opinions at the washington
post
quick point of fact universal background
checks so called universal background
checks which should involve
making if i give a gun to my wife
then i'd have to go through a background
check i'd have to go to a federal
licensed firearm dealer for example
that would not have stopped any of this
these guys would have passed background
checks in both ohio
and in el paso the attempt to
ban quote-unquote assault weapons has
always been extraordinarily vague the
new york post has a very bad editorial
today
talking about how trump should take
action on assault weapons it makes no
sense
whatsoever and the new york post
suggests
the second amendment leads ample room
for regulating gun rights just as every
other constitutional right
has its limits he they blame the nra
for all of this okay let's be real about
this the nra is popular because people
support gun rights
gun rights are not popular because the
nra is powerful anybody who suggests
differently doesn't understand the
dynamics of american politics or
purposefully are not doing so
because they are making a cynical
attempt to lump in support for the
second amendment with corruption
but the new york post says we need to
begin with a return to an assault
weapons ban
we know that label doesn't actually
describe a clear class of guns
some of the studies show the last ban in
effect from 94 to 2004
had a limited impact but that simply
means the next ban should be better
written
with a clear definition focused on
factors like firepower rate of fire
muzzle velocity etc
not on cosmetic features okay and then
people will use handguns which by the
way are responsible for vastly
more gun deaths and are used in vastly
more gun deaths than rifles are
and then the new york post editorial
foolishly says the supreme court has
ruled that the second amendment protects
the right to own guns in common use
that doesn't cover the semi-automatic
weapons regularly used only in mass
shootings that's nonsense
that's simply nonsense okay those are
guns in common use the ar-15 is the most
commonly owned
rifle in the united states a
semi-automatic rifle is just a rifle
that fires one bullet every time you
pull the trigger there are a hundred
million of those in circulation in the
united states
there is no magic gun that is only used
by mass shooters
we've seen handguns used we've seen
rifles used
i mean hell and in different countries
you've seen knives used so this is
this is not to suggest that there aren't
gun regulations that would be
appropriate i just suggested one the gun
violence restraining orders
but we're not going to settle on those
instead we're going to have a dumb
political fight over something that's
not going to get done because it's not
actually going to prevent the problem
charles cook has a good piece on this
over at national review
he says the editors finished their play
by running through a bunch of falsehoods
begged questions and non-sequiturs they
insist an assault weapons ban would
represent a moderate
unifying step it wouldn't such a move is
supported by only two in five americans
and has proven impossible to enforce
even in pro-regulation states
they suggest that the founding fathers
gave us the right to bear arms in a time
of muskets
and did not foresee the evolution of
weaponry this is false the founders did
not invent the right and they were fully
aware of innovations and technology and
throughout they assume that the debate
is between those who just want the
killings to stop and those who don't
care
unsurprisingly not true toward the end
of the missive the editors cite new york
city as the model
which it has to be said rather gives the
game away one of the big reasons crime
has fallen so far in new york city there
right is a crackdown on guns
that proposition is debatable but
irrespective of its veracity
for the post to mention new york city as
a model in the same piece as it decry's
extremists who see every marginal change
as nothing but a step on the road to a
universal ban
is ridiculous new york city has the
strictest gun laws in the country
so again there are honest policy
disagreements that can be had about all
of this
but that does not mean that we don't
care about mass shootings
and that continued suggestion which is a
holdover from going all the way back to
sandy hook
that is a it's a vile suggestion okay
okay so what are some of the other
things that have been proposed so
on the right there's been this this
upsurge in people talking about violent
video games trump himself
talked about violent video games in his
speech this morning
suggested that we need to crack down in
violent video games this
was also promoted by dan patrick who is
the lieutenant governor of texas he
suggested this on fox news
you know in this manifesto that we
believe is from the shooter
this manifesto he talks about living out
his super soldier fantasy
on call of duty we know that the video
game industry is bigger in the movie
industry and the music industry combined
and there have been studies that say it
impacts people and studies it says
it does not but i look at the common
denominators as a
60 some year old father and grandfather
myself what's changed in this country
we've always had guns we've always had
evil but what's changed where we see
this rash of shooting
and i and i see a a video game industry
that
that teaches young people to kill
okay so you know again the evidence for
this is extraordinarily scanty that the
video game industry is closely tied into
this
kevin mccarthy was getting half rightly
half wrongly grilled over this yesterday
he was on fox news specifically asked
about video games here's his response
the idea of these video games to
dehumanize individuals to
have a game of shooting individuals and
others i've always felt that is a
problem for
future generations and others we've
watched from studies
shown before of what it does to
individuals
when you look at these photos of how it
took place
you can see the actions within video
games and others but
what i'd like to do is make sure the
studies tend to show precisely the
reverse that these
violent video games really don't do
anything to link to all of this these
these chat boards where you have
actual human beings encouraging people
to go out there and quote unquote score
points as they did with the christchurch
shooter
that's a far bigger problem than people
playing video games in their basement
there are hundreds of millions of people
who play video games
very few of them are participating in
this sort of violence
now to end today you know there are no
things i like and know things i hate
because there's just a lot of stuff to
hate and mourn today
i just want to point out if we can't all
be on the same side on this stuff
then we're done as a country if we can't
all be on the same side
when we say that white supremacism is
evil when we say
that that it is an act of terror to
participate in an act of terror
that that violence is condemned by
everybody when we can't assume the good
faith of our neighbors when we can't
assume that we're all mourning today
then the country is done the country is
toast i mean
we all have to if we're not going to
mourn together over incidents like this
then we really can't live in a country
together because
morning is when you come together you
know in judaism we have something called
sitting shiva when somebody dies
we sit shiva and sitting shiva shiva
means seven you sit for seven days
and you don't go out of your house you
literally do not go out of your house
and people bring you meals and they come
and they pray with you and they come and
they sit with you
and they sit together because morning is
a time of community building
instead in america morning has become a
time to tear the other side a new one
by implying that they have bad
intentions
and i'm only saying that those who have
bad intentions have bad intentions if
they are
going to politically manipulate on the
basis of this
i think everybody of good heart is in
mourning today
and should be in morning because why
shouldn't we mourn why shouldn't we
mourn and why shouldn't we be motivated
to fight the evil
of these sick motherf why shouldn't we
should be
we should be i'll read you a story today
that just it breaks your heart
it's the worst story i've read in the
recent past it's just horrifying
this is from el paso cnn amanda jackson
emmanuel
greenberg writing el paso couples
shopping for school supplies dies trying
to shield their baby from gunfire
jordan and andre anchando brought their
infant son to walmart on saturday as
they shop for school supplies but only
the little boy
would survive the visit their relatives
told cnn the enchantos were killed
after a gunman opened fire in an el paso
shopping center on saturday
elizabeth terry and jessie jamarovsky
said the couple
who had just celebrated their one-year
wedding anniversary went to the store
after dropping their five-year-old
daughter at cheer practice terry said
as the gunfire erupted jordan shielded
her two-month-old son
andre meanwhile jumped in front of his
wife the baby still had her blood on him
you watch these things you see these
things you never think this is going to
happen to your family terry said
how do parents go school shopping and
then die shielding their baby from
bullets
the enchanters were among those killed
saturday and what authorities are
investigating is an act of domestic
terrorism
the third mass shooting in the u.s in
less than a week
jordan anchando died alone at the
hospital because no one was immediately
able to find her
said her aunt it took a while to confirm
and identify her throughout all the
chaos
late later saturday after holding out
hope for hours that andre on chando
might still be alive terry told cnn he
was confirmed dead
in addition to their two-month-old son
the couple had two more children age
five
and two god
this this piece of garbage
and damn all the people who refuse to
allow us
to mourn together to grieve together
and to fight together today that's
that's what we need to do as a country
and if we can't do that as a country
then we shouldn't be a country at all
alrighty i'll be back here a little bit
later today with a couple more hours of
content
or i'll see you here tomorrow hang in
there we will get through this together
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
robert sterling directed by mike joyner
executive producer jeremy boring senior
producer jonathan haye
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our technical producer is
austin stevens
edited by adam syavets audio is mixed by
mike coromina
hair and makeup is by jessua olvera
production assistant nick sheehan
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2019.
hey everyone it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
once again our country takes a hit from
satan's glove puppets
two people who are no longer fully human
because the devil got into them through
their broken places
and devoured the men god made them to be
one thing we know whether it's on the
right or the left
our national dialogue does not seem to
be helping
how can we change it let's talk about it
on the andrew clavin show i'm andrew
clavin